[Music]
McFarland USA is the true story about a
coach who is forced to move to a very
small town in California
after a brief altercation between a
student and his former football coaching
job this coach is played by the one and
only Kevin Costner and his family do not
want to be there in fact most of the
people in the town just look at him as
the white guy that moved in he attempts
to coach these kids at football but
quickly realizes that these guys can run
and they also work extremely hard
picking in the fields from dawn then
going to school and then working again
directly after school and then going to
practice with Kevin Costner it's crazy
for these kids but because of all of
this he sees something in them and he
decides to start a cross-country team
and from then on the movie gets really
awesome yeah I like McFarland USA I was
really surprised I went into this movie
a little bit concerned because February
inspirational sports movie based on a
true story all of these things we've
heard a thousand times it's gonna be
cliched you're gonna be able to predict
everything that's gonna happen and you
know what it is cliched and you can't
predict everything but the simple fact
of the matter is it's such a good story
the characters are actually well fleshed
out because the movie is actually less
about the cross-country matches and more
about these kids families and what's
going on in their lives and especially
Kevin Costner's life because he has two
daughters and a wife played by Maria
Bello and the movie becomes less about
cross-country matches and more about a
man discovering the idiosyncrasies of
another culture and that is where this
movie excelled I thought it was a really
wonderful story and there's a lot of
great scenes that are usually played for
comedy but sometimes not where Costner
is trying to connect with these kids and
discovering what they do all day in
these fields and how hard their lives
are it's actually pretty inspiring and I
think it was very wise of them to focus
more on that and less on the
cross-country meets yes there are some
suspenseful matches in the movie and
they work really well and these kids can
run man these guys can run my issues
with the film are that yes it is very
cliched you can predict where
everything's gonna go it does feel very
rote and a little bit familiar and
towards the third act of the movie it
actually got a little heavy-handed with
some of the family drama the first act
and the second act with him trying to
connect with the students and learning
about their culture I thought
was all fantastic but towards the third
act there's this big like scene where
it's like oh no things are getting oh
it's like it's so predictable and it
just didn't work for me but Costner is
just so eminently likable I mean you
just want to walk up to this man and
give him a hug I mean every time I've
seen Kevin Costner on the Strand I'd be
like dude just shake my hand man you're
cool you're awesome good job Kevin
Costner is the king of sports movies I
mean this guy's been in a ton of them
and Field of Dreams is my favorite
sports related film this movie inspired
me a lot when I was a kid and it got me
to actually make one of my first
feature-length movies called phenomenon
field it was 70 minutes long about a
magical baseball field and it's
laughable but if it wasn't for Field of
Dreams I wouldn't have done that so I
loved seeing Kevin Costner in a sports
movie and he was great he knocked it out
of the park in this movie no pun
intended so with the good performances
from Costner and the kids and the drama
that most of the time really worked I
had a really good time with McFarland
USA it was a nice refreshing simple fun
movie that I think your family can enjoy
adults and kids alike I'm gonna give
McFarland USA a B so we got a question
for you Bull Durham Field of Dreams for
the love of the game draft day and
McFarland USA which Kevin Costner sports
movie is your favorite also if you
missed my review for the Legend of Zelda
Majora's Mask 3d that is currently on my
channel I worked hard in that video I
had a good time making it I hope you
guys enjoy it guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes
[Music]